[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
me acompaña normalmente en los estudios
daniela blandón daniela vamos a hablar
de la unión europea que convocó una
reunión de emergencia para analizar los
precios de la electricidad sino golpes
de república checa que ocupa la
presidencia rotativa de la unión europea
y en donde está de visita el canciller
alemán olaf scholz propuso que los altos
precios de la energía se aborden como
bloque y no como país por eso en la
reunión energética que fue convocada
para el 9 de septiembre se van a
analizar propuestas como por ejemplo
limitar el precio del gas utilizado para
la producción de electricidad o
intervenciones para evitar el mal
funcionamiento del mercado y es que las
cotizaciones siguen por las nubes por
ejemplo el precio de la electricidad de
este lunes se pagaba a más de 630 euros
el megavatio ahora en alemania bélgica o
dinamarca y por encima de los 730 euros
en francia alemania italia rumanía
hungría croacia o austria una de las
iniciativas que se están planteando
desde la comisión europea es promover
una reforma estructural
al mercado de la electricidad ya veremos
entonces en qué termina todo vamos a ver
en qué termina daniela y queda en los
mercados arrastrados por las más
recientes declaraciones del presidente
de la reserva federal de eeuu pues toda
la semana pasada raúl los ojos de los
inversionistas estuvieron puestos en la
reunión anual de banqueros centrales en
jackson hole esto es en wyoming en eeuu
sobre todo en el discurso de yerba un
buen powell que es el presidente de la
reserva federal en efecto su mensaje
básico fue que la fed no va a dudar en
restringir el crédito para controlar la
inflación incluso mientras comienza una
recesión pero fue más allá y aseguró que
era probable que hubiera algo de dolor
para las familias y por muy altas que
fueran las tasas de interés no volverían
a bajar rápidamente este es un mensaje
para muchos cargados de pesimismo y
quizás el más duro pronunciado hasta el
momento al respecto wall street abrió
con pérdidas después de un viernes
oscuro para el olvido con descensos de
hasta el 4 por ciento en el caso del
nasdaq es tecnológico en asia la bolsa
de tokio cayó un 27 por ciento según lo
hizo en un porcentaje similar y otras
hong kong el hang seng chino llevaron a
la baja aunque en menor proporción ahora
veamos de europa los índices de las
principales bolsas también se redujeron
después de que uno de los miembros de la
junta del banco central europeo
advirtiera durante el fin de semana que
los bancos centrales deben actuar con
fuerza para combatir la inflación
escuchamos lo que piensan los analistas
de todo este asunto
creo que la fed está realmente atrapada
en una posición en la que llego tarde
para comenzar a ajustar se equivocaron
cuando dijeron que la inflación era
transitoria así que creo que todavía
estamos en una situación en la que gran
parte de estas presiones inflacionarias
va a ser determinada bien sea por la
guerra en ucrania o el kobe de 19 en
china hay demasiados factores que
podrían mantener la inflación mucho más
alta de lo que la mayoría de la gente
anticipa y eso realmente podría llevar a
la reserva federal a tener que ofrecer
incluso más aumentos de tasas de los que
está haciendo actualmente
cambiamos de información porque onda y
el fabricante de batería el eje y
apuestan a los vehículos eléctricos
daniela y raúl pues van a invertir 4.400
millones de dólares para construir una
nueva planta de baterías en eeuu a
medida que el fabricante de automóviles
japonés honda busca eliminar
completamente los vehículos de
combustibles fósiles para 2040 según la
agencia bloomberg la instalación tendrá
una capacidad anual de alrededor de 40
gigavatios hora y la producción en masa
está programada para comenzar a finales
del 25 este no es el primer negocio de
este tipo raúl ya los fabricantes de
automóviles de todo el mundo se han
venido esforzando por construir plantas
de baterías para automóviles eléctricos
principalmente en américa del norte y en
asociación con fabricantes de baterías
asiáticos de cara a cumplir con estas
metas de reducción de emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero
daniela cifra el día los 299 mil
millones de dólares que cuesta hoy
netflix en la bolsa de nueva york
esto lo traemos a colación porque el
domingo cumplió sus 25 años de fundación
en su momento esta era una empresa de
alquiler de películas en dvd y después
se convirtió en la primera plataforma de
streaming a nivel mundial uno de sus
fundadores reed hastings cuenta que se
le ocurrió crear esta compañía después
de que su videoclub de confianza le
cobrará una multa de 30 dólares por
devolver tarde la cinta apolo 3 mucha
rabia y dijo tengo mucha rabia voy a
crear una empresa y mire lo que creo
increíble gracias daniela como siempre
por toda la información económica nos
vemos mañana con más ergonomía en
directo américa